all right so as Texas fights arise in
kovat 19 cases the Department of Defense
deploying 580 military medical and
support personnel to help out here with
an inside look on the grounds is Texas
ER doctor Natasha Kathuria doctor thanks
for joining us what cities have you seen
and what information can you relay so I
work in Austin and I work sometimes in
Houston and in New Braunfels which is
outside of San Antonio and you know
between all those cities and I've
colleagues kind of across Texas things
are getting busy everywhere in every
main city in Texas we are stretching our
yards are stretching our ice cubes are
bulging at the seams and things are
getting very very busy even with normal
ER patients let alone all the Kovac
patients which are coming in so it's
been it's been very terrifying even the
patients that come in for non kovat
related things like a trauma patient for
example we end up finding out that they
have cooked ovid while they're in the ER
and so things get very very hectic at
that point because these are infectious
communicable diseases that we we very
much worry about so if someone tests
positive the internet they don't go for
hospitalization unless there begin to
fail
correct correct yeah if somebody comes
into the hospital we're not testing them
unless they need to be admitted but as
you can imagine a lot of trauma patients
a lot of pre surgical patients a lot of
patients that are being admitted for
other things we'll need imaging and on
that imaging we might see oh my gosh
they have kovat in their lungs now we
have to really attack this whole
situation very differently so I
understand Houston is so bad the mayor
there is calling for another lockdown
how bad is it in Houston I heard a week
ago they're running out of ICU beds
things are pretty bad in Houston right
now I mean they're working on bed
management they're stretching throughout
their limit some hospitals are already
well past that limit where we're you
know they're trying to shift patients
between hospitals to make a room they
have to keep these patients in certain
areas they can't just admit a kovat
positive patient anywhere so it's been
very difficult I mean there
even having to use the Children's
Hospital for backup for adult patients
which I mean that's pretty remarkable
that that's a that's a got the red flag
i watch that mature are over the weekend
he says that being the main difference
is from now in the spring is you know so
much more about it the ventilators are
really a last step now because some so
few recover from it and REM disappear
has been effective what can you tell me
it's been effective and are people
recovering oh absolutely our management
has changed of this disease we've
learned so much about it
we are intubating patients later we're
using blood thinners we are using from
the severe wound hospitals have it not
every patient will have access to that
medication it's they're very strict
guidelines on when we can start it our
management overall has changed I mean
with any new infectious disease as you
go along through the course so we're
better at managing it in these patients
and we are doing a better job in getting
more patients across the finish line but
what we're worried about right now is
the collateral damage when you overwhelm
a healthcare system with anything
especially an infectious disease like we
are right now
you don't just worry about the patients
dying from kovat then it's patients
dying of completely otherwise
preventable causes of death
you know appendicitis heart attack
strokes everything gets affected when a
healthcare system is overwhelmed and the
mortality of all of that has to be
included when we look at you know our
moral compass of how much we're willing
to sacrifice and tolerate before we step
in okay and real quick anything else
that you need because they are
responding for more pop up hospitals
tents conversion of stadiums I think
right now we're do we have backup plans
in place around the city to in every
city I know in San Antonio as well but
we don't want to get to that point where
we're outside of the hospital as you can
imagine you don't have access to
everything else the hospital has the
radiology the bloodwork everything else
gets transferred so we're really working
on personnel right now health care
workers frontline nurses respiratory
therapists that's really what our
manpower is our physician staffing is
okay right now but that's you know
that's teetering will
how that goes but it's really the nurses
and the respiratory therapists we're
already surged staffing from around the
state so we'll see how much we can
handle a or you know this blows out of
control
dr. Cathy Rhea thanks so much we'll
forward to checking it again hopefully
this week have better news me